two welcome everybody
to otr
right otr off the rails
oh
this is warfare now and it's actually
true today's episode
is about warfare
um we have such a fantastic show today
and we have no sponsors which means we
are officially off the rails accountable
to nobody
love the passion guys
so um welcome to the ryan cavanaugh is
running a ponzi scheme
podcast accused by his ex partner yeah
he's not running a ponzi scheme
necessarily he's been accused by his
ex-partner of running
bingo in as reported in variety
well anyway you guys know about that but
did you know
there's a new nugget of information
about cav cav
that is so crazy
so horrific it will explain everything
you need to know about this man
ryan kavanagh listen to this memo
from deadline now deadline like
variety dan and you can correct me
because you're you're in the biz
i'm in the biz i'm a big shop producer
just just like ryan once was not anymore
no he's bankrupt yeah he's bankrupt now
he bankrupted his production studio but
um
but yeah no deadlines uh yeah along with
variety hollywood reporter deadline
those are like the three
well it looks like their slogan is
breaking hollywood news since 2006 so
all the way back in 2006. that's not
that it's not that fast
they've uh they've had a stellar rise
like relativity media once did well i
mean but unlike relativity it's
still in business well hold on 2006
pretty early for a website let's not
poop with that i mean
ish yeah so anyway here listen to this
map listen to this headline
this is from 2018 not that long ago
relativity fabricated memo
claiming sexual harassment against
former co-president adam fields
judge awards 8.4 million okay now wait
wait till you read the freaking details
of this
in short there's this guy adam fields
who was a president they brought on to
relativity to save his
his failing bankrupt uh production
company
and when he decided he didn't want to
pay him anymore
this i'm paraphrasing the article okay
uh the judge said and i'll read her
quote or his quote i don't know the
gender
that ryan kavanaugh
forged a document claiming
he sexually harassed people so he could
fire him without paying him severance
are you is that like mental like
how like whoa
well wow forget this is the ryan
kavanagh forged the
document claiming his ex-president uh
sexually assaulted him or sexually
assaulted people so to avoid paying him
severance podcasts now this is sick
here i'm going to read all this oh
here's an update claim to sexual
harassment from seven women at
relativity against former relativity
co-president adams fields
have been found the result of a
fraudulent
memorandum devised according to the
arboreting judge
terry friedman by relativity ceo ryan
cavanaugh himself
bro the validity of that memo which
claimed that more than a handful of
women complained to hr
have been the subject have been
subjected to sexual harassment by fields
was also denied by the managing director
of the company
an overseer of hr carol jennis who
denied ever seeing or authoring that
memo so here's the thing
he brings in this document first this
this is so mental
he says i'm gonna fire this guy
because he's sexually harassing people
you know what's weird is in the
termination letter
it didn't say anything about um
the sexual harassment and then he mad
and then he magically produces this
letter
that was apparently written by this hr
person
and when the judge asked the hr person
did you sign this letter she says
no i've never heard of it i don't know
anything about what they're talking
about
weird the validity of them yada
here the validity of the memo which
claimed that more than a handful
in her testimony during a civil suit
brought by fields against kavanaugh and
relativity
she stated that she never heard of any
harassment claims and knew nothing of
them
the memorandum here this one gets great
a forensic audit of the computer was
conducted
and it was found that the memo had been
generated by someone who signed it as
cav cav who could that be
it certainly points to this man
wait is it this man or this man they
look so similar
i think it's him um
no no i think it was i think no
i think it's the other guy oh that's
yeah right yeah yeah
that's that's cap cav if if they had a
band together
those two would probably be called cav
cav um
probably be called essay oh i mean no
take that back ugh it's so awkward
well hold on i think we have a claim to
call it essay because he's falsified
memos about essay
he hasn't essayed somebody that we know
about but he's falsified memos about
essays right
so that's that's in the realm
dude can you guys believe what a scumbag
this frying kavanaugh is like what
the record states that two weeks before
trial relativity
magically discovered another two
thousand documents
that have previously not produ been
produced one of them was this hr memo
that was apparently written by genus the
hr person who had never heard of it
the document was a several page
memorandum which purported
to document a pattern of egregious
misconduct
by mr fields none of which strangely was
mentioned in his termination letter
an attempt to explain why the memorandum
had not been produced
earlier relatively relativity submitted
false declarations from mr kavanaugh
mr kavanaugh claimed in his declaration
that he was the one to ferret out the
location of the memorandum in particular
he declared under oath that he suspect
suspected that documents had not been
produced because it was in a private
folder
belonging to miss genus who was no
longer employed at relativity after
being given special
access to mrs genius supposed private
folders
he lied under oath a big
lie that's crazy so this guy should be
in jail
i don't know why you can just lie under
oath and just be like cool bye and about
something so serious he ruined this
guy's life
like he could not well he tried well no
he for like a year he almost couldn't
get work in hollywood
oh you read that i read that it was it
was hard for him to find
any work because he was accused of such
a horrible act
you know and this this coincided with
the harvey weinstein stuff right in the
midst of me too
so ryan kavanagh is a man willing to
weaponize
me to an essay such a serious topic
literally just to save him money from
from having to pay this guy his
contractual severance i mean there is
not a bigger scumbag
on this planet than ryan kavanaugh
also he's quite dumb too if i can say
that
he's he's actually quite dumb he said
last edited cav cav like the judge is
like you are an idiot
and you trust this guy to run trailer i
mean no wonder trailer's going bankrupt
[Music]
yo trailer no wonder their thing is
flipped
yeah yeah he wanted to ruin this guy
just to save just to save a few
a few bucks that's crazy
i mean basically falsely accusing
someone of me too stuff is basically
like
false r word accusations which is like
just the most horrible thing you can do
it's crazy man so disturbing
this guy wanted to come on our show by
the way
kavkev
uh field says in bankruptcy crediting uh
creditor
document at the first sight of this memo
he knew it was fake
that's the hr person jen or no janice
the hr person
was then brought in to an evidentiary
hearing to testify and was asked about
the memo
which claimed that three unnamed female
employees said that fields had
inappropriately propositioned them or
touched them
that one of those unnamed female
employees said fields suggested that he
couldn't
he that he could further
her career she said she thought it meant
in exchange for sex
and two other unnamed female employees
then led to the internal investigation
to two more females also in name seven
and all
so kavanaugh has has imagined a story
where this guy
is propositioning people for sexual
favors in turn for furthering their
career
these allegations in a filing on may
29th
states these allegations were all
fabrications seemingly ripped from the
headlines
of then recent harvey weinstein scandal
crazy you're a lion dog face pony
soldier
asked if there were three confirmed
incidents of harassment of female
employees by fields
the hr lady said absolutely not there
were no female employees that i was ever
aware of
asked whether a female employee talked
about his ability to increase her career
path
which she understood in exchange for sex
jenna said i no i am sorry i never heard
that
and it's unbelievable and then she the
hr
woman went further to say i have to say
i take sexual harassment extremely
seriously
and the fact that all this is attributed
to me is very offensive to me
honestly it is very offensive to me
that this is stated here when it did not
occur
in fact she said she was out sick the
day the memo was supposedly
written by her
here's when it gets great the judge
wrote
and i quote
let me zoom in i quote the judge
in conclusion the evidence was
overwhelming and undeniable
that relativity falsified the genus
memorandum
first the metadata the metadata refuted
all of relativity's theories linking
the memorandum to genus and established
that it was last modified on october
15th by cav cav
which must be kavanaugh
in fact the metadata revealed that the
hot issue folder where kavanaugh said he
found the memorandum contain other
documents that suspiciously indicated
someone was modifying documents
in the folder after janus left
relativity
second jenna's credibility
credibility credit credit
credibly credibility
credibly testified that she did not
write or edit this
it's credibility well it doesn't make
jenna's credibility testified
oh crap but that's the tense doesn't
make sense
uh i i i'm assuming it's a a type of
testimony to as to the credibility of
somebody second
jenna's credibility testified
let's move on
her critique of the memorandum style and
format rang true
for a lawyer with prior large firm
experience the most peculiar aspect of
the memorandum
was its repeated reference to kavanaugh
as co-ceo why would she add that
reference in a memo to her own file
he's writing he's he's stroking his own
ego in this falsified document do you
understand
how psychotic that is it would be
silly for her to do so she said finally
or that was what the judge said finally
had jen has been aware of sexual
harassment allegations against field she
surely would have included that in
fields termination letter
by falsify by falsifying the document to
manufacture
evidence that it had caused to terminate
fields relativity admitted that it
otherwise lacked cause the most
appropriate
sanction for such outrageous conduct is
in an
an issue sanction confirming what the
falsification revealed namely that the
relativity terminated fields without
cause
so anyway he won 8.4 million dollars
and so now you start to understand why
this [ __ ] went bankrupt
wow oh
you're right though i mean i'm trying to
pull that and thinking that
i mean it it sounds like it really
didn't take some serious detective work
to
uncover that basic forensics yeah also
well also the hr lady was like i didn't
write that right
but the damage was done to the guy's
reputation like you said a.b
right that's crazy you know
oh let me read their statement because
they get mad when i don't so here's what
they had to say here's what kavanaugh
had to say
had fields won anything but a single
count of breach of contract
against relativity where an npo would
have been more costly than anything
fields may yet be paid relativity would
have appealed i don't know what that
means
that's all you have to say it means
they're saying
it wasn't worth it for them to appeal
they're saying we're not appealing and
the reason we're not appealing is
because it's just cheaper for us to just
pay them off
okay so i find it interesting that in
their statement
they do not address the claim by the
judge
that ryan kavanaugh falsified a fake
me too document for a fake cause to fire
someone
that is [ __ ] bottom barrel [ __ ] shame
on you
you are you which one's him
is this him it's the other guy
that's ryan cavanaugh shame on you you
piece of [ __ ] scumbag dog [ __ ] of the
earth
who does that you ma you sir are
sick unforgivable sick go ahead
thank you i honestly it's one of the
worst things i've ever heard
it's one of the worst things a human can
do
especially during that me too [ __ ] i i
i'm blowing blown away
blown away your weapon i yeah he's
weaponizing it
it's horrible blown away well also it
trivializes the real accounts
exactly because this guy's like oh he it
shows he doesn't really care because
he's like oh look at all these
valid claims i can just sneak one in but
when you start faking [ __ ] then
everybody questions the
the the validity of all the other [ __ ]
like you're muddying the water dude you
are he must be a
sociopath i'm looking through the uh
the comments on this article which all
the comments are from 2018 when the
article was published
and it seems like you know within the
industry it was pretty
well known that this guy was a giant
piece of [ __ ] because it's just
everybody just piling on
oh well here's one that says i don't i'm
totally team kavanaugh and
this judge is an idiot written by a cav
cat
here's one ryan kevin this is anonymous
ryan cavanaugh is unhinged
unfeeling predatory psychopath for doing
this shame on him for hijacking the me
too movement and spitting in the face of
every woman
who has ever experienced sexual
harassment and or abuse
and he and by the way he's still out
there on twitter
on instagram acting like he's the new
dana white acting like
trailers all good he's tagging uh tick
tock stars
people need to tell he's tagging
tick-tock stars
and being like back me up on this ethan
guy people need to know
that this is the this is who he is
what kavanaugh did to adam fields was
egregious and cannot be allowed in civil
society
he should be prosecuted for defrauding
and defaming fields in order to avoid
his responsibilities
this must not be ignored by the media
otherwise we will send the wrong message
to our society
that this type of behavior is tolerated
weaponizing the metoo movement in this
way hurts a lot of innocent people
as we can see here
this ends me too exactly like
i i'm genuinely serious that this guy is
trying
he's trying to reinvent himself he
should never live this down
ever you know anyone that associates
with him
should know what the [ __ ] this guy does
it is crazy that he didn't get in bigger
trouble but i mean
i guess it's just a matter of the d.a
not having the time or resources to
go after something like this yeah
there's fraud
oh yeah it's clearly fraud oh yeah
totally yeah
that's not fraud oh it's not and
it's called false advertising thank you
jabril
and by the way i'm not a lawyer and in
no way is that a statement of fact
i'm just i'm just some dude on a podcast
but in my in the opinion of some dude on
a podcast that's fraud
yeah and so he's out there trying to
raise money for triller
but the the thing that really bothers me
is that people don't know
about this for some reason this really
went under the rug
and like again everybody who's
rubbing shoulders with him needs to know
that
this guy basically single-handedly
killed the metoo movement
[ __ ] unbelievable and dumb
just dumb anyway i
i was shocked i don't know if you guys
found that interesting i was absolutely
shocked by that
yeah i mean that is top tier [ __ ]
i mean just the the level of buffoonery
and like
you know trying to pull that off and
just immediately getting caught
is so embarrassing like how do you even
show your face after that
oh one other thing before we move on um
you know
you know how they updated it on
on the app store to say that on ios yeah
yeah they removed kevin hart which is
good because they listen to our feedback
but i actually have more feedback for
you guys because you didn't actually
update the
the androids the android store so i have
more feedback for you guys because here
it says
kevin [ __ ] heart who doesn't even
have an account
on your website you are a liar sir and
this may be fraud but i'm not a lawyer
to make that determination
uh so awesome so this is the man that's
suing me they even have a typo in their
[ __ ]
they have a typo here charlie d
slash apostrophe emilio
dude this is the man who's trying to go
public and raise money
he can't even do a [ __ ] app
description without typos in it
here the weekend doesn't the weeknd he
doesn't spell like that it's like
you know okay okay i stand corrected
i thought it was just the weekend
yeah so kevin hart is not on the app and
that's why i'm gonna be giving it
a one star uh from you know
my second phone
i have a second phone let me give it a
one star because this
but like they have a 3.5 here so that's
pretty interesting
oh it's so awkward slow cheap chopped
cheap
tick tock clone one of the worst apps
i've ever used laggy clunky yep sounds
about right
wait what was that last one throw it
back down
let's go back down to the last one oh
[ __ ] also i hear bad things about the
owner ryan cavanaugh i just heard a lot
of bad things about him
like how he's been accused by his ex
partner of running a ponzi scheme you
know now that we've what we just learned
that's not even that's
even close to the worst thing i know
about it's really not
i would say if i were to rewrite this
review i would say
ryan kavanagh falsified me to documents
and what's interesting about that one is
that's not an allegation that's actually
been proven in court
that's what the judge said right like i
was reading what the judge said verbatim
and their response didn't even refute it
which is what's interesting they were
like
it's not worth it too they're like yeah
you got us
you know also is trigger happy when it
comes to suing people which is just bad
business and a bad look
yep i couldn't agree more
couldn't agree more oh this one has 126
likes so people thought that was useful
yeah if i were to re if i were to write
a review today
i would probably mention something about
him
falsifying uh fake uh sexual assault
documents and
using me too to further uh his financial
interests pretty
scummy look at this and tell me there's
no such thing as a coincidence
you what am i looking at here this is
yeah exactly
half ryan kavanagh half harvey weinstein
and you tell
me they do not look freaking like
brothers
there's no such thing as a coincidence
are you kidding me you guys
tell me they don't look like brothers
hello
someone want to back me up dan you
you're the one that's saying he doesn't
look like him
um yeah i still don't see it
it looks like the same person aged a
couple years
uh it's [ __ ] uncanny you don't see it
how do you not see that dan that's like
dude
it's [ __ ] uncanny it's uncanny it's
uncanny and
well here let me further the agenda even
a little bit more
so he says he doesn't know
he doesn't associate with harvey
weinstein
well then why are you kissing his head
sir
that's ryan cavanaugh kissing harvey
weinstein
we love you daddy
this is him kissing his head and then
plotting to use his
allegations as weapons against people in
his own
firm thank you daddy now i can fire my
president
here he is daddy
wow look at him who's that on his left
[Music]
who's this is that his dad or that's
harvey weinstein oh oh
harvey yeah no that's not his dad not
his dad
wake up they look like they could be
family spot harvey weinstein and spot
ryan kavanagh go
here's the game i uh can't tell the
difference
i think this is ryan yeah i think that's
right just because the hair on
red hair yeah yeah so okay
that's my spiel for today i thought you
guys would find that interesting
you know this is what i'm up against a
man who will do
anything anything
suing evil
but anyway you know guys i've been going
vegan
i'm vegan this whole week vegan
soft clap not not enthusiastic
i can't applause so the guys thought it
would be fun to put together a vegan
taste test for me
they're vegan do you want to acknowledge
that you did this once
before and then made like a big deal
about it on the show and then like a
week later you stopped being vegan
sure acknowledged no why did i go vegan
the last time i went vegan i was i'll be
honest i didn't do it very good like
i was just i was like you can eat
whatever you want when you're vegan
and i was just like charging like cereal
and almond milk like huge
bowls of cereal every night and i was
just like going
i was going crazy because i was vegan
what's wrong
and um i didn't lose any weight but my
problem is like
i'm just so sick of this food battle
like this daily defeat
that i feel i'm just i'm so sick of
just hating my body and how i look
and thank you yes
and so i said you know what i don't want
to die
of heart disease i don't want to die
from being obese and all the health
problems and but most of all it's like
every day i just feel defeated like damn
why can't i lose weight
so i thought you know what man i'm just
i'm gonna go
vegan and i feel like it's gonna last
this time also i love animals let's be
honest i don't like the cruelty that
happens to animals i don't like
like when i see factories of of
pigs and cows and stuff and these are
beautiful creatures that i love and so
i love it it's it's it is there's always
been a sense of uh
hypocrisy within myself where i'm like
damn i absolutely hate
how animals were farmed but i'm not
having the willpower to do anything
about it
so like i like the whole vegan thing is
great it's great for everything it's
great for your health
it's great for the earth it's great for
the animals um
jordan peterson disagrees right here
goes the opposite direction
only me yeah well we'll see if i have a
sip of apple cider if i have an absolute
[ __ ]
meltdown for a year
somehow i think that uh i'll be fine
taking a sip of apple cider on the vegan
diet
right or maybe it's the inverse
if you're vegan for a while and then you
have like a little nibble
of a steak or something you'll be
overcome with an impending sense of doom
we'll find out well according to olivia
she was fine
because she was vegan yeah she was vegan
she had a bit of chicken she liked it
actually she actually enjoyed it so okay
so i guess it's just
the benzo addiction dude dude an
almighty diet is one is like
on par with uh i wouldn't say on par but
it's like
with falsifying a metoo document to fire
your president
just in that and that it's an extreme
place to go
you know ian are you just leaving the
camera on me for some reason
all right so let's get the vegan food
out here
so here now eli can't get mad at me
because we're eating
healthy food vegan food yeah i don't
know if it works
vegan food is healthy food everybody
knows that right before
we took the break you were just
explaining how last time you
did the vegan thing and you weren't
eating i was eating too much but it's
all healthy by definition
you can't get mad at me look at this
this i'm really excited to try because
this is going to be one food i
really miss is pizza yeah so that pizza
is from a place called cruiser's pizza
in
hollywood and the one you have is a
pineapple vegan pizza
dude you guys really knew how to do it
this is pineapple and all of like hello
who did that i mean god loves we know
you we know your preferences
appreciate that this is what uh chicken
wings i believe
yeah uh so there's some hot chicken
wings
and that comes from a place called
dummies also in hollywood
uh also the shrimp po boy
and the chili cheese fries and the mac
and cheese
are all from uh that same place called
dummies
wow yes sir wow and then finally
waffle and fried chicken
yep that's from a place called
crossroads kitchen on melrose and yeah
the chicken and waffles is from there
and i believe it's fried chicken
yeah and it's wednesday baby it is
wednesday it's wednesday you're gonna
have
chicken wings you know there is really
no such thing as a coincidence when it
comes down to it so true
all right well the first thing i want to
try you guys all have the food right uh
we have the pizza and the mac and cheese
let me try the pizza right now sure this
is a big one for me like
if they can figure this out
[Music]
hmm
interesting most vegan pizza up the
cheese is weird
this is pretty good this is like pretty
spot on
i'll be honest the flavors are there
the bread is delicious the sauce is
delicious
the cheese is a little [ __ ] a little
gummy okay
like how do they make this cheese i
think it's confused uh most of it's made
with cashews
i'm sorry a little [ __ ] yeah a little
cup a little [ __ ] is what you said
yeah you know what i mean
[Laughter]
i got it now smell it too it smells a
little [ __ ]
smells a little not sure how semen is
i'm not getting that i'm afraid but
i would happily eat this i would happily
eat a whole pie
i'm not i'm not 100 on the cheese like
i'm just not sure on the cheese right
now that's fair it was good until you
said a little [ __ ] now i just
threw me off dude doesn't bother me
[Laughter]
the texture is so weird it is [ __ ]
though right
no as you say yes yes yeah people like
semen
i'm guessing you all had a lot of [ __ ] in
your mouth
today i'm gonna come
zach ian anyone else want to give their
review
it's not bad i mean it's kind of
not bad i mean not bad
it's a vegan pizza i've had a long i've
had a long running debate with my
friends let me get your guys opinion on
this
not bad pretty good is there a why
that's a seinfeld joke
what that's a seinfeld joke oh well i'm
not aware of that
way to be original dan i'm kidding
i'm not even telling them a joke i'm
trying to say
is there a wide berth between
not bad and pretty good right or are
those equivalents pretty good is better
than not bad
you think it's you think it's a tier
above definitely i
i agree but i've had a lot of pushback
on that yeah it depends how you say it
you could say
you say not bad right that means you
like it
or you could say like it's pretty good
right you don't like it in the inverse
you could be like
it's not bad bad that's bad right
on the timbre of your voice or rather
wait i messed that up i meant
it's pretty good exactly like it's
pretty good well the way dan said it
that's my reaction
see that doesn't sound that good but
okay what if you say it at the same kind
of
place so you say it's pretty good
it's not bad right if you just neutral
tone
then then you're kind of in the same
zone see it's pretty good
it's been argued to me is that there's
not bad there actually there's a
transitive property there that they're
actually
equivalents because it does seem like
it's a lot in the tone
it's a lot and then it's all in the tone
it's all in the tone it's actually all
in the tone yeah not bad
now pretty good what if you're
describing a person
i think it works for everything right
yeah it's all about the tone i think
you're right
yeah but could that could you say the
same for anything let's say
it was bad um doesn't work it was good
we like that but then that like
inflection in your voice sounds like it
wasn't that great
like ah it was good you know usually
when you go high pitched when you add
that
you think i'm being sarcastic
let's try the um so you guys don't have
anything else we have the mac and cheese
come grab some of these
here i'm going to try the wing try that
one real interesting they've got
a bone a stick in it oh
to simulate the bone right
um kill him shredder [ __ ] fried
chicken
what do you think initial reaction
is it replacing a a chicken wing i don't
think anyone's gonna buy it
no is it good yeah it's pretty good not
bad
pretty good chicken wednesday baby
let's see give it a shot give one of
these a shot right now no i like it
though
i would actually like to try one of
those too
what the [ __ ] wait
yo that's good that one's good
yeah it's tasty it's not bad what is
that
what is the there's better than not bad
what is that
pretty good the meat in it it's just soy
boy soy bite
it's just soy it's interesting but
it's kind of like there's like a tuna
texture
inside it's gone see this is [ __ ] to me
that's not common everything can't be
[ __ ] this is why is everything coming
i'm not
i don't think it's coming no but ethan
does have this unique ability to
describe
food in a way in which it makes me
completely rethink it
now i taste tuna it was good it's
calming tuna
tune on a stick with barbecue sauce the
texture is not great
because it's like chopped meat like tuna
i don't know what the [ __ ] you guys are
talking about okay tuna in there
you've been vegan for too long well i'm
not vegan
but it's true i haven't had chicken
right over here how do we rate this not
good
or pretty good or not bad i'm gonna add
a damn in there
that one was pretty damn good damn that
one was pretty damn good
not bad i'll give it not bad wow and the
pizza is pretty good
damn damn all right let's try this mac
and cheese this one is a
tall order mac and cheese is dairy world
we're talking butter creams cheese how
can you possibly
emulate the experience of eating mac and
cheese vegan
like especially seeing what the kumi
cheese on the pizza
experience was because they're using
almonds like i'm sorry no
but it's it's got this gooey kind of
texture looking at it like this
nope nope that's bad
i i'm gonna reveal something right now
that i know people are going to get mad
at me for
not good but i can't judge this one
because
i do not like mac and cheese get the
[ __ ] out of here dan i don't like mac
i'm not a crazy i'm not crazy about mac
and cheese to be honest oh really
wait dude everybody gets so mad when i
say that i don't like pasta yeah
oh well i i never mind we don't we don't
stand together it's an american staple
it's like baseball
yeah like all americans well okay we'll
try it
i think i tried it i mean it's okay like
i don't know i just don't like mac and
cheese
so i can't really do it i can still tell
the difference i mean what kind of
i mean it tastes pretty mac and cheesy
to me which i don't like so
it tastes like almond nut what about mac
and cheese do you not like
uh i don't i don't i don't like uh
velveeta or like fake cheese
when people make like a really good mac
with like actual cheese and [ __ ]
oh they're having a little moment back
there behind yeah they're having a
little fika
moment yeah i guess i won't completely
dismiss
all mac and cheeses you know you can
have like a gourmet mac but uh like the
blue box [ __ ] or like mac and cheese
with velveeta i just don't like velveeta
like velveeta is just [ __ ] you don't
make all mac and cheese with velveeta i
would never
i was acknowledging that yes all right
does anyone is there something that's
not
a hater dan the hater think that um this
is good in any way
it's i like it i'm not a fan of it
really i like it
i'll tell you what's making me sick is
that fake chicken that's that's not
sitting right with me
what the [ __ ] that was the best one so
there's something about it it's not
sitting right
i it's i don't think the vegans have
figured out cheese i don't think they
should try
just don't try they've got they've done
a pretty good job figuring out meat and
stuff
right but the cheese is a work in
progress people
it's too gummy all right this po boy
here i'm going to take a bite and then
i'll pass it off to you guys now i don't
like shrimp i'll just put that out there
so i'm not sure how this is going to
translate
absolutely flavorless
okay we're off to a good start
look at this thing it looks great ain't
nothing poe about this boy
yo got him
how's that for a sandwich
i'd skip it it's a skip i don't like it
that's a big ass second bite for
something you're skipping
that flies on camera man i think
it's honestly not bad i'm being a little
harsh on it i think it's been sitting
out a little bit because there was a
gathering process
i think if i got that fresh i'd be very
happy with it dude that fly
you want to show them your your bug
assault well i think we've shown it yeah
yeah dan shot me with it last time on
camera uh did i
but now i have it i'm playing when you
shoot she did you scared me too much
i'm playing go ahead zach
any time there's a fly dennis grab
running around this assault weapon i'm
like dude
it's not just me it's become a it's
become a blood sport here in the office
i think uh ian has the highest body
count by far actually what's your kill
death ratio
uh well infinite because i have not died
to a fly
not yet it i don't use it no more
because it almost ruined mine and zach's
friendship
so i just i don't use it well the [ __ ]
almost shot out my eye
you shot at his face that's why no i it
ricocheted it ricocheted
but it's enough to piss him off so he
got big man dan river
it really hurt like i i it was like i
apologize
it's different if i aimed it at you it
wasn't it wasn't just the salt it was
like the impact of it
like it ricocheted off the like toys i
understand but it's a complete accident
it could have just easily happened to me
okay it's an accident but it's still
it's still hurt well it wasn't like hot
when you were behind you i was like no
you were
i definitely wasn't i said i'm sorry you
could give less of a [ __ ]
i said no at the end of the day never
mind
compassionate not a compassionate person
hey speaking of zach being mad didn't
you have something you wanted to share
with uh ethan oh yeah
um you know you called me out on the
last taste test for like eating the food
before
yeah and before we started running oh
here we [ __ ] go
i dare you therefore no no go ahead i'm
just saying
[ __ ] say what you have to say this is
this is you tried the food before man it
was a french fry i don't care
i've never had it i'm testing vegan food
i got a backup zac on this it was just
he had to say what he had a single
nugget he had one
damn nothing what's the whole test you
read sitting there eating the whole
[ __ ] thing
and you're like it's french fries it
doesn't matter i've eaten french fries
french fries aren't vegan okay
this doesn't matter if you're eating a
nugget that's the whole
test well that is that is true okay but
how can you even make a computer this is
a better a b
you back them up on that you know
backwards yeah you know go ahead
go ahead you've presented a good point
[ __ ] in the food type the nugget
was the heart of the world
but the betrayal but okay this is not
just nuggets this is an
array of things the french fries are
part of the i'm not reviewing the french
fries
dude french fries are not vegan part of
whatever is on there chili cheese fries
that's the review i was eating plain
fruit
those aren't oh there was plain fries
with the wings
that i was eating i'm still calling
[ __ ] okay well
okay anyone want to back zach up
upon the revelation of this new
information i'm not it wasn't the chili
cheese fries here oh my god okay the
fact you still were i was with you with
food
i was before but it wasn't it wasn't it
wasn't the food that he was eating isn't
the target of the taste test
it doesn't matter yes it does i feel
like it does actually matter a lot
doesn't matter you're still eating
before therefore your palate is not
cleansed oh that's the issue a cleansed
palette yes
you're moving the goalpost this is some
[ __ ] man
and i get yelled at
so i'm calling you out okay well
everybody's against you
fine they usually are i'm still holding
my ground
you want to talk about it did i upset
you last week when i called you out
no it's all in good fun but i just
wanted to you know
point it out like here would be
comparable if i started eating the pizza
then i would say yes i would say you
know what you caught me
yep it's a good argument i'm still
calling [ __ ] i love you but i'm
still calling
you really okay let me let me set a
different situation if there was a bowl
of
pretzels here and i started eating the
pretzels would you be mad about that
well what was is the pretzels part of
the taste test are we still doing them
the french fries aren't part of the
taste test hold on wait are the pretzels
part of the taste test no this is just a
bowl just a bowl
so we're doing the vegan taste test and
you just have pretzels
yeah then no but
considering that the french fries are
part they're not taste
from the restaurant they're not they're
from the restaurant they are therefore
similar flavors the chili cheese fries
are part of the taste test
the french fries was a side a plain side
of french fries that came with the
buffalo wings that i ate
okay but not partial chili cheese fries
and french fries are basically the same
thing
therefore you were dipping and trying
the meal
basically the same thing is a big
[ __ ] difference when the whole point
is the chili and cheese which is um
this is the whole vegan experiment it's
still fries
oh my god it's still prized
ian back me up good ian what are you
gonna say
look to give zach a little something
because he's out on the line a little
bit
you be honest though ian well
mainly i have my headphones on i don't
like hearing you wolfing down the front
like you were going to town during the
break okay but that's not what's at
debate here
we're not debating it by what i'm about
for example when you get like sushi or
something you have a bunch of different
rolls
you usually hit the ginger right to kind
of cleanse a little bit yeah pellet
cleanse
this is a variety of things you were
like vacuuming those fries the fact that
i'm
vacuuming fries has nothing to do
with the vegan challenge it's from the
same rest take off your headphones ian
who's forcing you to listen to that it's
always working dude
yeah right yeah i'm just brother
it's uh you know it throws a little
wrench i don't know if i can believe
your reviews now okay all right just the
backpack it doesn't make any
was i eating any of this before we
started
zach made me look at him while i'm not
accusing you of that
you did last time yeah because you did
you
did it too i oh my god zach
yeah okay i will i will end this yeah
i'm sorry zack you know i love you i'm
going out of town tomorrow i'm going to
miss you zach
but the chicken segment the whole thing
was about how popeyes was claiming that
this was the revolutionary nugget that
was going to change the world
and that we were going to try it and see
if this was a
the nugget of all nuggets how do we know
these are real french fries they could
be vegan
hold on hold on what are you talking
about i don't know what vegan or no
it is i don't know it's a potato zack
that's not vegan
it's not the same okay oh boy potatoes
not vegan you want to explain that one
no
let's just let's let's end this let's
end this right there
all right let's move on yeah i love you
thank you i love you i was very
passionate all right let's move on to
the uh
the heated chili cheese fries yup
if that's okay with you hey man i'm
holding my [ __ ] tongue right now
all right here we go
again i don't think the cheese is there
i don't think
i don't know about all this i don't like
it
it's not bad here you want to pass this
around we i just
had one oh you have one mm-hmm yeah
unfortunately
it's salty well i mean
chili cheese fries are usually pretty
[ __ ] salty that's not
too out of the ordinary i mean i think
it's too salty
uh okay
i think it was pretty good you all
you guys all got a taste
i meant more of this pizza yes so far
the pizza is my favorite i'll be honest
by far which is pretty cool for me
because
you know how i feel about pizza your
pizza boy your big old pizza boy since
you said come
i'm just like what are you yeah vegan
cheese has just come
home there's just a [ __ ] factory of men
just
viewing on these items that in the mix
of the
and it's not even accurate not only is
it gross but it's just inaccurate it's
deadly accurate what's it made out of
what cashews nut how do you guys know
how extra or not
i rest my case he got you there man
you got me so good right there i'm gonna
come
there you go all right now we got the
chicken and waffles here we go
are these real waffles or
what's a vegan waffle
[Music]
there's syrup what is the other one
i'm not super familiar with chicken and
waffle culture
uh i'll just butter ew
oh my god i just dipped in butter
it's not garlic well it's not butter
butter is not vegan fried chicken
oh that's impressive it tastes just like
butter oh is that
[ __ ] or no enough with the gummy jesus
do not come
hmm
yeah i know uh chicken waffles it was
like a thing in the south for a long
time
it it kind of want to try this you guys
got
ian has one ian what do you think
this is probably my favorite favorite
one i think the chick the fried chicken
is really good
oh it's like 100 there
nice [ __ ] fried chicken chicken
of all the the fake meats chicken is the
one that they've perfected the most
like i i've had lots of people try
various fake chickens that that eat meat
and be like i
cannot tell the difference between this
and regular chicken yeah that's not
there for
for pork it's it's still a ways off why
would you even try
well some people like pork obviously but
no i think yeah the fried chicken if
you're in the fried chicken that
that hits nice one compliment i will
give is the beyond burger
now that that's pretty close yeah the
beyond burgers are
are pretty good yeah pretty pretty
they've just perfected ground beef like
specifically hamburgers right right
and yeah the beyond burger is great
oh there's a dessert yes yes sir that is
a brownie sundae
oh my goodness here come come get a shot
of this
a brownie sundae now this is all dairy
right this is all three yeah
eggs cream cream eggs
chocolate it's all there butter
maybe he's getting lost this is a uh
what is this a
fudge sunday brownie sunday it says
yum and that is from the same place as
the chicken and waffles so i think that
might just be your favorite place out of
these three
oh so there's a strong flavor of coconut
cream okay i gotta make brown
which i just really happen to like that
but it tastes like coconut ice cream you
know
yeah i guess yeah that makes sense
instead of using
flavors there for nail bear i don't know
what this is would you give it a pretty
good
is it blueberry yes that is a blueberry
it's like a candied blueberry hmm
moving on to the fudge moving on to the
fudge
i'm a mother freaking blueberry yo
not good it's hard
but it melts in your mouth get some of
that
ice cream on there wow
all right well crossroads kitchen seems
to be the winner
this dessert slap damn so if you're
already
if you're in la or visiting and uh you
want some vegan food crossroads kitchen
on melrose is the place to go and by the
way these are like candied blueberries
they're like
nice mmm
it tastes like it was like soaked in
like a simple syrup or something
nice oh now i'm a strawberry
you slam that whole thing no anyway in
summary
the desserts are banging bro i love that
coconut cream
sure the cheese is coming everybody
agrees
except for me everybody but dan thinks
that the
the cheese is coming i'm going to come
but you do agree dan um come
no yeah everyone thinks you might be a
little sucks because you go
i don't know what you're talking about
everyone's like it's definitely coming
come it's just what does that even mean
oh what does it come i mean yeah come
comey it's like gooey it looks [ __ ] it
it acts [ __ ] it's nutty
it's come actually nutty it's it's just
i'm just kidding because i know it's
made of
almond kami is a state of it's it's more
state of my experience
okay semen is a good idea
yeah well some people think drinking
semen is a good idea absolutely
sussy so anyway we have a discussion
topic we want to do today
about cringe stories i know we've done
kind of something similar but
uh because they're always so much fun we
can never forget abe's donkey kong story
that we have to keep sharing so
um let's do it who wants to go first
with cringe story
why don't you uh lead us off this one
is really okay so this story that i'm
about to share
i have never shared with anybody it's
something
it's one of those memories where you'll
just stop and
remember it somewhere where you are and
just cringe hard
and you're like why why am i me
i wish i could be someone else right now
and the thing is i don't know if the
story's going to resonate
with you guys at home as hard as it hit
me
but just know as i'm telling this if it
misses
that this is one of the most painful
memories hurtful memories i have wow
okay
exciting so let's say
in high school
i was um
i wasn't like a cool kid but you got you
guys it may surprise you to know but i
was very fit in high school i played
waterfowl
waterfollow it doesn't surprise me
because you bring it up
a lot
right
right i like to relive those moments i
need to set the stage here dan
did i mention i'm vegan today
so i there was a moment
in high school where i was very
desirable
okay
there's this one girl at school she was
straight up
like the hottest girl at school that all
the dudes wanted you know there's like
one or two or three girls who was like
she's the she's the hottest girl at
school
gnarlier the better thank you
and funnily enough she has the same
exact
last name as me with like some variation
so we were always next to each other
in the yearbook so anyway we're sitting
next to each other at graduation
and we really hit it off we were joking
and flirting
and i felt like you know we were we
really uh
made a connection and we
exchanged contact information and we
started hanging out and chatting and
calling and i was like wow like you know
this girl's really cool and smart and
like i actually
you know there was like a little romance
for me let the conversation
and i was like wow this is crazy like
i'm actually forming some kind of
romance with this girl
um so
one thing led to another i took her out
on a date i was
i did like a super tryhard day too like
i took her to the beach
i found out like her favorite cake and
got that and stuff
and like i was like super try hard mode
bought her a cake
a sl i found it she she's like obsessed
with this one dessert so i got the
like a slice of it okay i didn't bring
the whole [ __ ] cake
no that's that sounds like something i
would do today not back then
yeah she she like liked tiramisu i found
out so i went to like a nice italian
restaurant and got a slice of cake
first to share the beach not a bad move
thank you i was trying like i said i was
trying really hard
and um you know
we had good dates we went to the movies
anyway so
things are progressing and then i was
just
trying so hard right so uh yada yada we
come back to my house one day
i live with my parents by the way so
that's already awkward enough because
this was like free
uh college so we go up to my room
things are going one way we start making
out i was like
okay and dude i don't know
what i don't know
why but i felt like i'm gonna
i was doing everything right and i
wanted to like
just blow her mind at what a good kisser
i was
and i start and i don't know why i've
never done this since and i've never did
it before
i was started like licking her of like
lips a lot
when we were making out and then
and then i was trying to be like really
sensual or something
okay like the outside of her lips yeah
like with her mouth closed
no we were making out but i was doing
like it's hard to say it's too painful
yeah i was licking her lips a lot
okay and so she
stops me and she says oh
so are you like the licking guy
like that's your move and i was so
embarrassed
brutal i was so [ __ ] embarrassed
i didn't even say anything to defend
myself i was like oh my god what have i
done
and i feel like there was a way for me
to recover but i just was so embarrassed
i couldn't i just like
so you were at your house did you just
leave after that
so so anyway i was super embarrassed we
kept hanging out a little bit longer
then she
she the night like um
ended she went home and we never talked
again
that was it yeah
we never talked again that was the end
of my romantic connection with her
that's brutal and that felt so bad
because i obviously maybe the tiramisu
wasn't good
maybe i had nothing to do with the lip
licking
it was the licking maybe you wanted to
lick the tiramisu off her lips you know
get around the mouth so wait what i'm
sorry she said are you the licking guy
or a looking guy she said like oh so
you're the licking guy
so did you have a reputation for like no
i think she was just trying to make a
joke okay i think she was trying to
acknowledge that like
she hated it right and maybe trying to
make a joke out of it and trying to get
me to stop
yes one of the things they do is called
enolicki
and i was just so gutted because i had
done everything right i really liked her
i was trying so hard
and everything had culminated this
moment was like wow we have this
romantic moment we're making out and i
just
i don't know why i did this and it was
and i i just wanted to die i just wanted
to die
and she went home and we never [ __ ]
talked again
and i haven't talked to her since and no
leaking brutal
that's a good one damn dude i i think
back on that moment still to this day
and and wince yeah
wow we appreciate your courage that
wasn't i'm sure that wasn't easy to
share
the licking guy i mean that still
resonates in my head today
just shut down while having that first
special moment together
it was so i was such a bad kisser that
she we never talked again
and everything else was right what grade
were you in
yeah that was after graduation before
college okay okay so i was like pretty
well you know
i was probably like 18 19 maybe i was
like
a grown-up i mean quote-unquote sure
it's always an interesting summer after
yeah [ __ ] goes down that summer boy
oh yeah you know damn
so embarrassing and my friends were
always like what happened like you guys
were really hitting it off because it
was kind of like a thing because she was
like the popular girl yeah they're like
what happened you guys were really
hanging off i was like
i don't talk about it dude i just
avoided it
i never thought i could ever tell it is
this the first time you told anybody
yeah
yeah oh my god it's the first time i've
ever uttered those words out into the
world
wow brutal that is wild
and i don't know if she wanted me to
follow up on her i got the feeling she
didn't and i was so embarrassed anyway
that i felt like i had to i had to exit
the whole situation yeah
you should have just turned it on her
it's been like man your lips really dry
i was just trying to
help you out help you out there there
was no there was every
all the air was sucked out of my sail
like i've never been so speechless and
embarrassed
and it's not her fault it's totally my
fault and like i could have
i could have saved this the moment if i
would have said something but i didn't
even acknowledge it
i just stopped you were putting on a
pedestal
uh yeah i don't know
something sort of similar happened to me
once uh
i don't even know the mechanics of how
it happened but same thing it was like
the most popular girl in school
this is like around time we got to
college
and we were kissing or something and i
can't even like figure out in my head
how it happened
but somehow i had my arms around her
and i i thought i was kissing her and i
accidentally kissed my own
[ __ ] arm
did she notice yeah she would not
[ __ ] stop laughing
wait was she was laughing at you so
that's not that bad
it wasn't that bad it was so [ __ ] it
was such a central kiss
on my own oh it's like a sensual kiss
you were so in the moment you didn't
realize wait wait okay so hold on
you had your arm around her and you guys
were making out
yeah was it dark like how do you how did
you make that mistake
either it was dark or my eyes were
closed and you missed her head and
then made out with your arm like you
didn't know the difference between your
lips and your arms
and then so what how did you react to
that
she said did you just get you
that's good that's a good one and i go
no i go no no
i'm like i didn't know what to do i was
like yeah i thought it was you
and she just died laughing oh my god but
that seems like salvageable if she's
laughing like art my moment was like
dead silence end of relationship right
yeah
mine was dead silence i don't know if
she was joking or what but like
there was just dead silence i don't know
there was music in the background
so what happened did you guys was that
did that kill the relationship or no
i think so i think something else came
up like my roommate came home or
something and so
because i remember telling her like
don't tell him about the arm
[Laughter]
she for sure told people don't tell him
about the arm like you really didn't
want people to know about it
i think it's funny i don't think i've
even told lena that story i'll just
give you a big fat kiss
that's like out of a movie man that's
pretty amazing if that was in a movie
i wouldn't believe it i'd like to kiss
his arm instead of the girl
oh i have another good one i'll share
since we're on the topic of awkward
hookups
college first year
i was really vibing with this girl went
back to the dorm to like just hang out
and watch stuff
i had a roommate we
shared a room on opposite sides
but he had the tv so we
just said we're gonna just sit on his
bed and watch tv
but he's not there so we start like
we're not like doing it but we're like
making out it's like one thing leads to
another we start making out
and we don't think like oh let's let's
move to the other bed
like i know he wouldn't mind us sitting
on his bed and watching tv
but the lights are off and we start
making out and touch you feely and stuff
and then i thought he was like gone and
then he busts open the door
and he's got a big 12 pack of like
orange sodas or something and he's all
excited he goes yo
ethan i've got sodas and then he sees us
in his bed
and then without saying anything just
walk down
so that was pretty bad too oh
that's a homie right there though yeah
that's a real one yeah yeah yeah no he
was i'd been like get the [ __ ] out of my
room
he was a homie he was at home man but i
think he just didn't know what to do he
was just shocked to see
and like i was like oh my god dude and i
don't even
here's the thing i don't even know if
she knew that that was his bed
you were like damn i got this bomb ass
flat screen in my room
trying to play it off like is yours
that's funny all everything we had in
college was super ghetto it was like an
ancient [ __ ] box crt baby
yeah that that just reminded me of that
that was a good one
[Laughter]
[Music]
we joked about that all high school oh
my god stop playing the yoko
yes i don't need to hear that anymore
jesus she's the worst
we joked about that all throughout
college i've got sodas
[Laughter]
that's a good one that's a good one too
all right so i got that off my chest
yeah well i i mean i had a i have a
cringe story it's not uh
it's not making out related uh so it's a
little bit of a departure but
um this was in high school as well
i believe it was the summer between my
freshman year and my sophomore year uh
so after the first year of high school
i had flunked uh biology
and so i needed to retake it you're you
were a bad student that's supposed to oh
big time
really yeah i just never ever did
homework or paid attention or i was very
were you would you jelly
is there friction with your parents
about that uh
not as much as there probably should
have been
interesting they just they weren't very
strict i mean i not to say that they
well as this story relates to that so
um yeah i i flunked uh biology in ninth
grade mostly for
a lack of caring and trying and so i
needed to retake it in summer school
i had never taken summer school before
uh i don't think they did it in middle
school
um so this was like the first time for
me
in summer in the marvel universe
[Laughter]
and so the first time for me in
the marvel universe so i show up on the
first day
and the way it worked is like you you go
into class and
uh and they register i think because a
lot of people they sign up for summer
school but then they don't show up
so you're officially registered after
you like sign in that first day
and so i'm in there for like the first
period of it
i believe the summer school class was
like they're long
they were like four hours long or
something wow so i
stayed for like the first two hours of
it and then
it went on like lunch break or whatever
and i
walked directly over to the music
department because i was
involved in band and all that kind of
stuff and i was like
i'm not taking biology i'm just gonna
i'm just gonna take this music class
instead
um it doesn't work that way right well
no of course not
uh i mean i still got i would get credit
for the music class but i obviously
would not get credit for biology
which is why you were there i made an
executive decision that i was not going
to be
spending my summer learning biology fair
enough um but i
had to go to summer school so for the
entirety of the summer my parents
thought i was leaving every day to go
take biology and i would just go to
school and go to the band room
and that's pretty ballsy playing music
and so i had this teacher uh that was
our music teacher he was really cool uh
you know
typical like cool guy band teacher you
know what i mean
very relaxed with the rules and
everything and so
i think he was vaguely aware of the fact
that i wasn't supposed to be taking his
class
really i think he was like kind of
vaguely aware of it but you know
probably didn't like fully understand
what was going on there
so he just let me stick around spent the
whole summer doing it
and i don't remember how the [ __ ] i
convinced him of this but at the end of
the summer they give you a report card
right
and my parents wanted to see it to make
sure that i had passed and i was like
okay well this is where i'm [ __ ]
because i don't have a report card from
a biology class and somehow i convinced
him
to give me my report card with my grade
for band which was an a
because i did a great job uh with the
thank you thank you thank you
but he gave it to me with
the subject the class blank i somehow
convinced him
to do and so i just wrote biology
on that line wow and gave it to my
parents
yeah all good right i pulled it off
i successfully spent the summer not
taking biology and my parents are none
the wiser
flash forward to about six months later
or something
again like i said i wasn't a great
student i was having especially at that
time there was a lot of other factors
going on that i won't go into but i was
just
struggling in school and
i had a meeting with a counselor and my
both of my parents
and so we go into the office and they're
going over
like you know what kind of my status and
what classes i still need to pass and
everything
and she's like yeah and he still needs
to retake biology
and my parents are like no he took
biology last summer
right dan and
god i i
i just froze i i had no idea where to go
from there i knew i was completely
[ __ ] cornered
it's just and you know is our school was
built in the
[ __ ] 40s or something so tiny room
like just in this tiny room like nowhere
to even avert your eyes probably
jail sell it yes just in this tiny ass
room
with my mom and my dad on the left and
right and my counselor directly across
from me
and they're like yeah you took biology
last summer right
and i just i i literally
i couldn't even speak i was just like i
don't i don't know
at that age that is the worst possible
scenario
that's painful it was it was one of the
most painful memories of my life
obviously i like i said my parents were
very lenient with school but that was
one of the times that i got [ __ ]
ripped into
uh grounded for a good while after that
will play out the scenario like what
happened how did it come out
uh well that's where it came out i guess
i i guess i had to cop to it
uh in that meeting i mean you you said
no i didn't take it yeah
yeah yeah i i confess i fully i fully
confess to you in front of
guidance i don't think i did in front of
the guidance counselor i waited until
i got home and kind of explained exactly
what had happened that summer
um but yeah i mean i was riding so high
man i thought i got away with it
scot-free
i was like so like when i when i
convinced my teacher to leave the
subject line off of there
i was like i'm a [ __ ] genius like i
did this you flew too high
yeah you flew way too [ __ ] high yeah
and um
that was sort of a you know as cringe as
it was it
it was a bit of a turning point i think
at that point was when
i uh realized i needed to start actually
taking school a little bit seriously if
i
if i didn't want to not graduate high
school and
that was the only thing more cringed
than that situation was
the thought of flunking out of high
school yeah i was like all right i gotta
like
put in like 15 effort here to at least
get c's or whatever
you know i would say it could be worse i
mean you could have just
skipped school altogether right yeah i
mean i actually came close to dropping
out i was sort of
considering you know what do you call
the ged or whatever just dropping out
and doing that
yeah i i just i don't know i i don't
know if it was a maturity thing or what
and like i said i mean there was a lot
going on in my life
in my teenage years uh that was
contributing to this but
i was terrible in school like i just
never
like i just didn't do homework like
period like i just didn't do it
you know i two people in my family are
teachers my brother-in-law my brother
and they changed the rules now where
people you just can't flunk like you
literally they don't
flunk people oh wow really because their
whole philosophy is now is like
dropping out of high school oh you were
talking about this on families the other
day that's right
oh did we touch on it you touched on a
little bit but they say dropping out of
high school
is not good for anybody
right we did talk about it yeah yeah
yeah
yeah you can't even flunk out of high
school now which is interesting
yeah i don't know how i mean as somebody
that would have benefited greatly from
that i still don't know how i feel about
that
because i think that i think the
pressure
and the fear of being the guy that
flunked out of high school
it did help me get motivated basically
my
ninth and tenth grade year was i was a
terrible student
i made up for it in my uh junior and
senior year i think the people
generally who flunk out of high school
are people from really bad families
really by
bad financial situations really social
but you pulled it together and got
through
whereas someone like that they just they
don't see
they just don't see the point so you
know yeah
i get it in certain situations but yeah
very interesting stuff there dan you got
busted i
busted big time i really haven't thought
about that
in a decade or two as well because took
band
took band got an a though like i said
for that class
bro crushed baby i played the trombone
at the time
i played all the brass and uh nerd
hey i wasn't a [ __ ] clarinet player
all right
i'm just kidding the band kids are i i
the band kids are cool i was a major
band kid i was in marching band all that
i was the drum major in my senior year
that's right you were the drum major
yeah there was a few
so maybe not the drum major i was a drum
major
let's say but yes did you like the movie
drum line
with nick cannon you know that movie
came out when i was in high school
and when i was in marching band yeah you
were
no not not so much the thing was i don't
know if it's like this for everybody but
the
drum the the drum line in marching band
at our school and from what i've heard
always kind of has a rep they're they're
the
they're the they're the meat heads
they're the meat heads of the band and
heads yeah a little bit okay
and um so no
i mean i wasn't really that big a fan of
drumline oh okay
were you you liked that movie um
no i never watched it when i was a kid
love don't cause the thing when it canon
i don't
that's that's a story for another time
all right let's move it on
um ian you got one for us
yeah yeah i got one uh i don't know if
i've told this on the show i don't think
i have
and i asked the guys they don't remember
stop me if i have
but this is like one of the most
embarrassing things that i've ever done
in my entire life
great love that that still has
implications on me
to this day does it have to do with this
show
no okay no this was before okay got me
worried
so uh
right after i graduated high school i
kind of wanted to try stand-up so that
was my thing
i don't know i think i've told you this
story in private yes
we've never told this story on air i
don't think so
well there's another story this isn't
this isn't the writing story oh i was
thinking of the writing story
you want to tell the writing story
because that one's pretty good too no
this one's worse
okay go ahead i love it so cause he's
told the writing story on the show but i
don't think he's told this one he's
okay this one i got reminded of it
because of all the twitch
stuff and being called reaction andes
and all that stuff so
i went to try stand up and i was very
new
and i was very insecure and nervous
about it because i was
i was so new i'd done it like two times
at this point
and i got this weird idea in my head
that when they asked for my name
i thought i'm gonna put a different name
that's not my name and then when i
bomb and i'm really painfully unfunny
it's like that guy bombed not me your
name is clean
yeah it was like a like a hard reset in
my mind it was just like a little mental
trick
so you were you were genuinely going up
under a pseudonym
just to get some practice under the belt
yeah yeah essentially just to kind of
get over my nerves a little bit
okay so i use the name andy
which is andy slater just like my normal
um
because my middle name so uh i
did this and i put my name in and they
called me
and it went okay it was whatever but
then
afterwards i started talking to another
guy there
who was also doing stand-up and he goes
hey andy right and i'm in my head i'm
like
well you know it's okay sure
i didn't want to explain it because i i
figured this was just a little chit chat
and so i was like yeah yeah good to meet
you
and then we started talking and talking
and talking and then
at the end of it he asked me for my
phone number if we wanted to
do stand-up again or hang out
and he types my into his phone andy
and asks for my number so
at this point i'm like i'm in too deep
yeah i was too embarrassed at that point
yeah
so i just i went with it
and then i heard from him and he invited
me to this like
social event and then he invited me to
this little film project he was working
on
and every time all of these hey everyone
this is
my friend andy right you becoming andy
and then i
met a couple people at these various
events
so this was this was i don't know
six seven years ago to this day there's
about nine people in my life who think
my name is andy
so you're coming out right now as ian
well i think that's out of the bag
already
[Laughter]
he knows he knows but even still he'll
come over and he'll
call me andy he's like i can't not call
you oh you guys are still friends
yeah yeah you're an andy andy
yeah i'm an andy andy yeah it's so
embarrassing
it doesn't strike me as that bad you
you got a pseudonym they got a little
far but like you could have just played
it off like oh it's my
you know it's my stage name and well
mainly because it wasn't a stage name
though it was like a
one it's i did it one time
and i've been in handy for like eight
years
it's kind of interesting how
how these one evening though can have
such a long
standing uh how much can happen from one
evening look how many people you met
the aunt that andy met it's a butterfly
effect andy
right there it's an anti-fly butterfly
andy butterfly andy
well thank you for sharing that and we
love it
you want to share the writing story i
feel like yeah people are going to want
to know what's the writing story
i think i've told that before it was a
while ago i think there's plenty of
people who
haven't heard it was a long time ago
that he told that story yeah
okay i'll speed run it so the last time
i ever did stand up ever
i was trying to do some stupid ass like
andy kaufman
thing i thought was clever i don't know
it was wasn't that good
but the concept was that um that
you know when you're giving a speech
sometimes people write
uh little reminders on their palm or
something so
in case they forget their lines they'll
kind of like look at the palm to
remember
so what i did was i came up with this
long bit that was like
like like paige's worth and the joke was
that i was gonna
go up and act like i was forgetting my
routine and then kind of look at my hand
to remind myself
and then it gets bigger and bigger and i
have to like
roll my sleeves and it would be covered
in writing
of my joke as a reminder and it would be
all over my body you would take your
shirt off
yeah yeah and then it would end where i
start to like unbutton my pants and then
i go it's not even that funny and i walk
off so that was my
genius idea it's not a bad idea we all
agree it's not a bad idea
yeah so anyways before before the show i
went
and i got a marker and i
wrote this like novel of information
all over my body and then i put my shirt
on and i went to this open mic
and it was really hot in there like like
stupid hot and the ceilings it was like
seven
foot tall ceilings and everyone was
crammed in
and i was in the back waiting for my
turn and i was going like oh my god and
i looked at the guy next to me i'm like
it's kind of hot in here right he's like
uh that's all right you know it is and i
started
kind of getting getting a little worried
and i went to the bathroom
to kind of calm my nerves and make sure
everything was good and i end up in my
shirt and my whole body was just
blue like blue man group
all of the ink had just melted
and i'm like i i'm in there and i'm
grabbing tissues and i'm like scrubbing
the trash can is just
overflowing like someone murdered a
smurf in there or something
just like blue covered uh
paper towels and and then i heard my
name
and i just ran out oh you left you
didn't even do it
i should have told that story yeah
because that's really funny
i agree or you could have just rolled
with it and like integrated into the bit
that like
yeah you take off your shirt like oh god
oh god just start sweating and like
being like
but that's amazing you just bounced and
you never performed again
went out on a high note yeah
that was the end of the stand-up career
folks
i try by the way i always encourage ian
i think he's very funny that he should
do stand up yeah
those days are behind him like he said
according to him but i encouraged him i
said do some
write some material come out here come
out here and do a
do a routine no no i like behind
behind the scenes that story really hit
ian home because we get like after that
he's just like a he doesn't want to
leave the darkness i know i'm in the
shadow realm now
damn shadow realm andy
um we just have zach left right
i'm gonna give him and love if love has
one oh let's go do love because we
always
accidentally skip poor love you got one
love bot
i don't know i didn't put that much time
into thinking about
this uh for some reason i've just like
blocked out all the really awkward
moments in my life
sure but there's this one thing that
came up um
uh well two i i can't i can't tell two
short ones so
in school i was always the one that like
couldn't stop laughing i always laughed
at [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] we just had the laughing
contest and you said nothing makes you
laugh
well yeah but when when you're with
friends and stuff oh you're when you're
with friends
when you're with people that are
actually funny right yeah unlike here
sitting over here in sweden in a dark
room right
well anyways uh so
this teacher for some reason was talking
about
like some really brutal [ __ ] that had
happened to him
and mike just reminded me of the worst
thing ever
story ever sorry so like death
death stuff and me and my friend just
for some reason just
lock eyes and we like
no no don't do like it
smiling at each other yeah and it just
evolves
i'm sure like a lot of people have yeah
the same experience but
totally this was so inappropriate he was
talking about some really really dark
[ __ ] that had happened with his family
or his dad or something oh no
yeah and we just like literally start
laughing
and we have to leave the classroom
because we just die and we couldn't go
back in we had
all our stuff in there we couldn't go
back in so we just
stayed outside his uh
classroom for the rest of the rest of
the day
did you guys ever debrief it with the
teacher or explain
or was it just ignored no no yeah
we just hoped they had forget tonight
next week
and just because it was so short i i
have this other story
in my school always the first thing that
the teacher does when they come into the
classroom
is they put in their pc into the
projector so it like shares the screen
and for some reason this teacher had
facebook on
facebook notifications oh and he left
the classroom and a bunch of weird stuff
started coming in from his notifications
well like shooting stuff like like weird
stuff from a girl
that we know is not his wife's name
interesting so he was getting like
sexual kindness not sexual but like
flirty
weirdly intimate stuff okay intimate
messages from a woman who's not his wife
yeah we even checked out what his wife's
name was wow okay
interesting and yeah i just started a
huge rumor that it was
uh he was cheating on his wife which was
pretty funny then we
poor guy he's probably a sister or
something
that actually reminds me of a story i
used to be really good friends with this
guy in high school we had kind of the
same dynamic where
we you would catch eyes just start
laughing at the worst moment
like for example we worked for we both
worked for this gardener
who was a really devout jehovah's
witness and he started talk
i just i started the conversation i was
curious like
and so this is why it makes it so [ __ ]
up i
was asking like so what's the deal with
your faith he's so because like his
whole life's about his faith and
everything
and he starts talking about like you
know
really serious stuff and we look at each
other and start laughing
like i asked him and i start [ __ ]
laughing at him
he goes yeah it does sound kind of goofy
but that's just to set the stage
okay so i was a poetry this is honestly
so [ __ ] up you guys and
i'm gonna tell this story it wasn't
funny it was horrible
this i didn't want this to happen and i
feel so bad so please don't think ill of
me
but we were both uh poetry
we were both poetry majors
writers and we had a mutual friend who
was a girl that we were all friends with
and she's like i've been writing a
poetry do you guys want to hear it like
she kept trying to get
she kept trying to read us her poetry
and we're like cool let's hear it
so we go to a room it's a small room
it's just the three of us in this room
and she starts reading this poem we
didn't know what to expect
she starts reading this it's very
intimate very
uh vulnerable about her being assaulted
something really vulnerable right an
emotional
powerful beautiful poem
about her being essayed or some just
that's what the sense was it's something
horrible right that left this huge
impact on her
is something about there's like an
inverse
a formula for like how inappropriate it
is to laugh
that makes it irresistible sure yeah and
so
for just no good reason i catch eyes
with kareem or
well he's my friend and like
[Laughter]
well just like for a small smile creep
up
on one of our faces just knowing
just because we're both thinking the
same thing like it's so [ __ ] up if we
laugh like don't laugh
don't laugh
and we kept looking at each other and
then
we're just in the room that there was
she's reading this heartbreaking poem
we're just sitting there like trying to
laugh it's so [ __ ] up you guys and
like in my mind it was so painful i so
didn't want to laugh it was so painful
and i just i
i wanted to just like stop so badly
and she was like pretending like she
didn't notice but obviously she did
because it was like
and she just kept reading the whole
thing and we were just we were just
like like stifling laughter
just the two of us in her room and we
were [ __ ]
laughing at her it was so [ __ ] up
but it wasn't it wasn't like tears it
wasn't laughter of joy it was
pain it was just like self-loathing
laughter like i couldn't help myself
yeah i just don't it was just so painful
you guys oh
god i'm so sorry to her
i'm so so sorry to her that makes me
think of my grandma's funeral me and my
cousins were all kicked out by my dad
my cut real fast my cousin came in late
and he sits next to me
and islamic funerals you sit up with all
the men women family set up up front
on each side my cousin turns to me and
say what did i miss
because he came in late and i said turns
out she's not dead
and then it just started
[Laughter]
it started a chain reaction that got us
all kicked out by my father sitting in
front
it could not stop laughing
you can't ask what did i miss at a
funeral that's what we
set you up so so well for that i thought
you were gonna say she died
what did you miss oh she died uh but
yeah
she didn't die works too that's so
[ __ ] funny
jesus your dad must have been pissed
now you have a big time big time
oops zacky did you go uh no
but i i thought of a story all right
let's hear it is it
[ __ ] on someone's lawn no no no um
which i'm not cringing at i'm
still very proud of that yes i don't
know why but um
we love you for that you know i'm known
as a very cringed person and you know a
lot of things i do i just
i just do i don't find them cringy um
this story
the joker brain yes joker brain which in
itself is cringe to a lot of people but
whatever no it's cool yeah it is
this story makes me cringe so this says
a lot
okay so i was about 15 and
i had a horrible case of swamp ass
now if you've ever had that it's a
horrible thing it's very what is swamp
ass
it's like you know you find your term
yeah um
you know you had a long day of like
diarrhea or whatever
your [ __ ] is just raw and your cheeks
are red
and you know what have you i thought
swamp
was just sweaty ass but this is you're
talking about there was a dramatic kind
of
uh experience at your ass there was
there was sweat involved yes yeah
it was a full whammy okay so i had this
and
the same night we were going to an event
it was one of my dad's
clients and um
i i needed something for pain relief
um so i put this product on like a a
vaseline but it's called rosebud
and it helps with the chafing rosebud
yeah it helped with the chafing and i
caked this [ __ ] on like finger right on
your butthole
yeah so you went to the bathroom and
just put it right on right on in your
ass this was before
we were leaving okay okay you know on
the cheeks all that
yep and you know it was during summer so
it was a hot night
you know uh we go to the event and the
guy's like hey like
you want to go for a ride in my new
ferrari and it's this beautiful 458
ferrari
gorgeous and i'm like yeah sure so we go
in i'm in the car i'm sitting there and
you know like ian's story it was hot
and i liked ian's story it was hot it
was hot yeah
and i feel this like squish
as i'm sitting in the car as we're
riding around and yeah
um i'm like what is that totally forgot
that i put the rosebud on
rosebud and i'm wearing shorts and i get
up
out of the car and i see on the seat
the whole where you sit
is just covered in this grease
and just rose bud
and i'm horrified
thank god when we got out of the car the
dude didn't see it
but he knew i not at the moment no but
he
like i'm sure later on he knew i never i
never
heard a nail trailer what is wrong with
this kid he left
he left right now
holy [ __ ] so i still cringe at that
probably stunk too
oh yeah oh yeah so he must have thought
you were like the most
vile kid he's ever met he this kid left
a stinky
grease trail on my brand new car man
that's awesome i uh yeah that
that horrifies me i've never heard a
word
from him or my dad about did it was it
like just
did it look like your ass and legs or
was it just grease everywhere there was
grease everywhere
all over it brand new [ __ ]
so the back of your pants must have been
all wet and greasy
oh dude also there's another layer to
this but
maybe there's maybe there's multiple uh
rosebud creams or something i i was just
curious because i never heard of this
brand before so i just googled rosebud
cream and the first result
is an organic vulvar and vaginal
skincare
is that what you use that's not it now
are you sure 150
okay it does look like they have some
other products that's just the first
thing that comes up
on google this is this is like a
vaseline like a lip balm but you use it
for like
okay okay i was wondering if that'd be
[ __ ] funny though yeah
but yeah that that story makes me cringe
yeah that's bad
yeah i'm glad that makes you cringe i
would question your sanity if that
didn't make you cringe
so that's my story okay guy you must
have used a lot of that product oh i
caked it on because this is what i'm
seeing
and i don't know exactly what it was but
like i'm just thinking
you'd have to use a lot of vaseline to
get that i was hurting that day dude
like it was bad rosebud salve yeah
that's it that's okay
that's the stuff okay let's see what
this is
smith's rosebud salve
a trade secret blend of essential oils
cottonseed oil and a spectral
and a special petroleum base
rosebud perfumes so mussels had a it
must have had a nice
rosy shitty like that's exactly
scent it it seeped through my underwear
it seeped through the shorts
i mean it was just horrifying
horrifying you got you
you got the best stories buddy i mean
that with the [ __ ] on the grass is
just
which that doesn't i don't cringe at
that i'm very proud of that story why
are you proud of [ __ ] on someone's
grass
how many people how many people can say
they did that
a lot like homeless people like every
homeless person i don't know but when
you're in a predicament when you're on
your way to somewhere and your stomach
is dropping and you can't hold it what
are you gonna do
you can't hold it i would rather [ __ ] my
pants than drop trout and [ __ ] on
something
if you remember in my story i i tried
[ __ ] my pants in the car
at my body why'd you have to get on the
grass do it in the gutter or something
i it was the only place i found
i hopped off the freeway and i'm like i
gotta go now
i'm glad you can live with yourself you
gotta go you gotta go i suppose
yeah so we've heard from everybody uh
maybe i guess technically you haven't
yeah sorry i mean the only reason i
still want to share this because i
really had to dig deep for it
okay so some context
uh in my hometown a lot of the dudes are
really buff like they're really big
dudes
the best way i could describe it quickly
is like it's like the arab version
of like guidos and jersey shore like
yeah
and uh ethan bradbury type of thing no
no no like bigger than
big buff dudes okay like super jacked
yeah okay and uh so one night
me and a bunch of my co-workers were all
really close and some of my friends went
to the club
and uh i had one friend who i was really
close with she was like
we were really close but she's a little
older than me she was kind of like my
wing girl she was
she's really cool but um she's really
pretty and uh
she was talking to some dude at the time
and so her friends left and she asked if
we could
take her home at the end of the night
her and my uh me my friend phiraz
and so she was talking to some new guy
and she was
going to his place and so we're driving
him there these are back in my days when
i was uh
still drinking so i was really drunk and
i was in the backseat of my friend's
mustang
fidos is in front and then my my friend
my girlfriend in front
my friend who's a girl and uh so she
calls the guy that she's
talking to at the time and this guy is
like
screaming at her like what if i'm going
to be like like going nuts like at her
like i've been [ __ ] and i'm like
bro what's wrong with this guy and so
i'm a little [ __ ] up
give me the phone give me the phone i
was like passed out in the back prior to
this
you're drunk yes i take the phone
and uh right before i i start talking
she goes
no no he he goes to lava which is the
restaurant that we work at
so he might recognize me she says so
i was like i'll change my voice my drunk
self
for whatever reason like i guess i was
thinking a lot of people in our my
hometown don't know pop culture that
well
so i started imitating the emperor from
star wars
and so like give me an example of what
that might have sounded like
uh so i was like uh i
i was talking to her like that and he's
like he's like
he goes what he goes who the [ __ ] is
this i go
i don't know don't worry about it he's
like
he's like who the [ __ ] is he he starts
getting like really mad screaming at me
don't worry about it and then he goes uh
he goes whoo
he goes who likes screaming at me and i
go i am descended
everyone in this car starts cracking up
and then she starts [ __ ] then she's
laughing
and then he starts flipping out and he
goes uh
and he goes uh what are you guys high
and he's like i'm gonna beat the [ __ ]
out of you and i go good
good give it to you i hate and i just
keep going with it and he keeps getting
and i'm cracking up we're all laughing
i'm not thinking anything and then we
start to get closer
and i see he has a green lamborghini
and then it clicks to me who this guy is
this guy looks just like an air version
of the rock
he's rich he's got a lambo he gets a
lambo he's like six
[ __ ] four and he's just [ __ ] diesel
he's
he's obviously jacked up on roy's or
something huge
and then i look and he's standing
outside waiting for us to roll up and i
and i'm i'm telling my friend fridas i'm
like [ __ ] go go go go go go take her
take her to one of her friends house and
my friend firos who's also a tough guy
he goes if he [ __ ] this guy we could
take him i'm like no no no no i can't
take him go go go go go
he and he goes if you stop being a [ __ ]
i'm just saying no no no no
no no no we get close and he starts
walking up to the car
and like my friend fidos for every
reason thinks we could take him
how big how big is your buddy he's
shorter than me
and he's like i mean he he's he's kind
of
you know big but he's like five seven
he's short
shark king yeah and so for whatever
reason in my drunk
palpatine rage i reach through the seats
and i grab my friend's nipples and i
give him a titty twister
and i scream go as i'm squeezing his
tits
and that worked and he just gunned it
and then we dropped her off at her
friend's house
and uh yeah that was there was that was
the story i recognized the guy and uh
we're cool now but i was i was just very
embarrassed by that
squeezing my friend's tits and saying go
because he's he's not the type to
to roll with that so so was he angry at
the tit uh
the tip maneuver at first he's like he's
like abra what the [ __ ] was that and
then he's like
i'm like sorry dude i just i we
definitely couldn't take him then he
goes
he kept driving and goes
maybe like like it's like 10 minutes
later maybe i can't believe you really
just squeezed my tits like that
i don't know how to feel about that and
i was like yeah
i was desperate time we just had to i
had a gun a titty twister
double titty twister man
and did you guys ever talk about it
after the uh i can't believe you did
that
every chance these two had my friend in
the car both of my friends in the car
told the story of me giving a titty
twister as i was afraid of getting my
ass beat by
the arab rock
fantastic [ __ ] that's what he was about
to say to me
yeah titty twister i mean i got a titty
twister once from one of the guys at
water polo like one of the older guys
and i felt
so violated and i didn't even know this
guy
yeah and first of all it's extremely
painful and very uh
humiliating and i was like
i was like i'm gonna [ __ ] kill this
guy like i was so upset
and i was like i'm i'm i was like
i can't believe you did that too i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill him
i was ready to kill him i was plotting i
was just i was
i was just so i couldn't believe that
happened
so yeah the titty twister is uh
definitely i don't know i've had it once
and it felt it left
it left a big impact on me titties i
don't think he ever talked
to me again because he i was like i
think i looked like i was in a murderous
rage
he was way bigger than me so i wasn't
gonna fight him or something
that wasn't on the table he was probably
expecting you to just laugh it off or
whatever and the fact that you got no
pissed i was gonna
i was like i'm plotting your death right
now in my head
yeah someone gave me a very painful
titty twister in middle school and
they're like name five cereals and i was
in so much and i couldn't think and i'm
like orioles
chips ahoy he's like cereals while he's
like twisting my whole
nip yeah i don't yeah i don't miss that
about being a kid that like
a big part of it was just uh hurting
each other
yeah thinking that that was funny you
know what i mean like
there was a lot of that going on growing
up some kid gave me a five star one time
in fourth grade
what's a five star uh it's just like you
take your hand like and you just slap
someone on the back as hard as you can
oh okay yeah and you know they're like
little names for things
yeah cute little cute names dude i knew
a guy or i
actually didn't know him but it was just
somebody in my class uh who
do you remember kids used to do this
sometimes where you'd go up behind
somebody and with your knee you'd hit
the back of their knees
so somebody did that to this guy in my
high school and
without realizing the person that he did
it to like had recently had something
wrong with his leg or something
and he [ __ ] like blew out his kneecap
i like collapsed and
ended up having an ambulance come but
like and thinking back it's just like
kids here's this here's one from middle
school um
i was like involved because i was guess
i was friends with the kid doing it and
i knew the kid he was doing it too
he goes wouldn't it be funny
if i peed in a coke can a coke bottle
and gave it to him and he drank it
and we were all like i guess that'd be
funny so he took half a coke bottle went
to the bathroom pissed in the bottle
gave it to him and then what's weird is
he took the bottle
and like who just takes a coke bottle
from someone they don't know that well
and then drinks it he drank his piss and
then the police came
it turned into a whole thing and they
called on us to testify
what it was like this whole crazy thing
and i'm like what is this
it's too nasty actually yeah like that
very wild that's nice
that happened sorry go ahead yeah i'm
delayed
uh do you guys know about anything
that's called buddha buddha
yeah it's a similar like thing you do to
people or
buddha for some reason kids did to each
other when i was young
yeah so basically you go like this and
you go from behind
you just shove your hand up that and
[ __ ] spread it oh i think that's a
new one
i see kids on tick tock doing that i
think sometimes that's like
people did that to me when i was a kid
like
foreign seriously
like a violation yeah it sounds like
straight up like almost borderline
r word yeah there was uh there was a
similar thing
growing up what did they call it it's
like elephant something or other
and somebody come up behind you and grab
you by the shoulders and put their knee
into your ass like really hard yeah we
make like an elephant sound you know
what i mean we used to do
when i was a kid called ropi ropi where
you would put them in your trunk
sedate them with a drug tie their arms
and legs up in a rope
yeah keep them in your dungeon and then
perform unspeakable axe on them for a
week
right yeah it's called the ropey ropie
yeah i remember that and then you let
him go i used to do that one all the
time yeah
it's hilarious ethan your story reminded
me of the the piss in the coke
some kid did that at my high school
except it was with his load
[Music]
yeah he ended up getting expelled bro
oh brother disgusting so did someone
drink the snap
yeah he drank the whole [ __ ] thing
and then he's like ah i came in the
snapple and like
oh my see now that see that's coming
right there
that tastes comfortable yep
that is literally coming for sure i
think that that's the most
[ __ ] up thing everything yes kids are
wild man pretty well we actually have to
wrap it up how are we doing how are we
doing on time here
uh we do need to wrap it up we're almost
in two hours uh fantastic i'm sorry
we do have one more submission uh from
cameron
oh cameron come share your story
he linked and uh we have time
yeah of course we got time for you
stand up cam um stand up you want me to
pull this picture up of you in high
school
yeah holy [ __ ] cameron this is you in
high school yeah
i'm not as gifted as a storyteller as
all you guys are so bro
look at those bracelets a picture is
worth a thousand uh cringe stories and
there's a few uh have you ever posted
this to blender years the subreddit
blender years i've never heard of it but
i should check it out
okay you just gotta post this photo to
blunder years well keep looking keep
looking it gets worse
hold on i'm still enjoying this one yeah
yeah we're taking all of this in so you
have a communist shirt on
yep i was a bit of a i i don't know
anything about marx's theory really i
just uh
i don't know it was for the people yeah
clearly i was most popular in high
school yes this kind of attack dude
those bracelets what was your theory on
all the bracelets
um i like the way they look and uh i
still wear some bracelets to this day
but not that many
and there's also if you look very
closely there's also a fish
sweat band there from the band fish oh
hello oh big fish
big fish energy coming off of it
i have a cringe story with the guy who
created adventure time oh pendleton ward
yes uh oh i would love to hear that i'm
a big stan you might want us
we we might have to save it for next
time next time a little teaser for next
time because we really are
pretty this is one that i think back on
in terror and shame
oh yeah that is good that is a good
cliffhanger i'd love to hear it yeah for
the next one next week
yeah i was about to say that oh my god
those bracelets remind me of
convention wait those bracelets remind
me of prank invasion
oh yeah clearly i made made out with a
lot of girls yeah how was your
circulation not cut off
you look so different i mean pro i mean
look you you your your skin looks
beautiful
i mean you don't you look so different
what what are you trying to say what's
wrong with this photo huh my skin's not
beautiful here
it's like a jackson pollock painting
i'm just saying you've blocked you've
blossomed didn't do a fine younger they
glow up
as they say blow up they glow up little
bit yeah you've had a glow up and the
last photo is my uh
rosie o'donnell although bob dylan
called bob dillinger i got that at the
bob dylan show he was a horrible uh here
you look good
you look good here that's my rosie
no you look fine here you look fine uh i
still wear that
flannel from time to time oh my god no
that's amazing you can fit in
clothes from high school that's
something i can never do i would say fit
in
great but sorry to yeah this is fine you
look great here i'm not gonna hate on
this poor little kid
i am but you know thanks for giving me
the opportunity to share these you know
have a great day everybody but you
should definitely submit this to blunder
years i think people would love this
photo
specifically yeah that's a prime target
let's analyze this real quick uh okay we
got the guy fox mask
guy fox mask uh green lantern shirt a
lot of xbox 360 games there
yeah what's the uh is that a tibetan
flag
that is a flag at a bet yeah okay you
know
make
doesn't even look like a poster it's
like a banner it is a banner yeah
don't take don't take this the wrong way
but in this specific photo
you kind of look like a young james
charles oh god
oh no i don't see it oh no i don't see
it
i don't see it i'm desperate
that there's that does resonate i'm
desperate energy that photo right there
yeah really sad i'm really sad
you're really sad all right remind me to
tell the uh the adventure
okay i'll put a note in the dark but
yeah we are we are past the two hour
threshold now so we should uh
rip it up he asked me for a photo
because i was with justin roiland at
some kind of event
oh i was at the the telling the story
yeah
but he was a fan of mine he wanted a
photo and something happened
that i think made him never want to know
me oh got it you're leaving a little
okay i like this little till next time
yeah i don't we'll save that for next
time yeah i'll hold on to that thought
oh no oh no
oh no sister snatched
all right bye guys bye